when you won that goal the first person
i thought about was your mom i mean she
must have had a moment knowing that your
dream just came true like has it all
sunk in no not yet um i mean i've been
so busy
so i haven't got a chance to really just
sink it all in yeah i mean of course
when i get a moment to myself it
definitely will
what was that feeling when you got home
with mia and your kids how did they
respond did the kids even respond they
were like yeah good job dad or were they
like over the moon yeah no they were
just happy that i was i was home uh
at first they saw on tv and they were
jumping up and they were happy i showed
them the medals and everything but they
were just happy that i was home because
i hadn't been home for about you know
seven weeks on top of all of this you
partner with godaddy canada for the
don't stop being unstoppable a campaign
which highlights the unstoppable spirit
of the canadian small business owners
it's overcoming every challenge who made
you feel unstoppable
yeah i mean just really just my support
system you know without them there would
be no andre the grass so i got to give
thanks to my mom of course my girlfriend
of course my kids always motivate me
every day you know especially canada as
well now you have six medals where are
they in your house where do you put them
i have no idea yet i'm not sure i'm not
sure what i'm gonna do with these medals
they're in my backpack still so
there's there's saw your backpack really
yeah yeah i haven't got a chance to
really unpack yet stuff is just
everywhere right now